I apologize to the people of Denmark and of Scandinavia. Bryce is trying to take away your ranking. We've got two hours and ten minutes, it says, until we get to Copenhagen. Probably going to run out of stickers. We'll save that discussion for when it happens. Use modern C++. Polestar, it's a big swing to miss. And also, it's not like a, you know, a microcontroller.
They're running Linux there, but it's a limited memory environment. Basically, everyone at Roku listens to ADSP. Cheetah, like, you know, going after this Impala. And buy Tesla next time, folks. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 254 recorded on September 19, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we record live from Denmark on the way from Orhus to Copenhagen, we chat about the Roku Engineering Symposium that we attended the previous day, including a plethora of other random topics. This episode is pure chaos.
We're back, folks, on the beautiful roads of Denmark. Hello to our Danish listeners. We have acquired a bunch of information about the countries of Europe and Scandinavia. Tell us why are we in a car, Bryce? This was not planned. This was not planned. We were going to take a train like, you know,
the European way. We were going to take a train from our hosts where we currently are to Copenhagen today. We'll explain why in a moment. But the important thing is that we got on the train. Now, Connor's phone kind of died overnight. So there was
there was some question about whether she was going to make it in time because I was about to go to the train station, couldn't reach Connor, had to go knock on his door, and then he woke up and I was like, well, I'm going to go to the train station, you meet me there, but he made it in time, train left the station, and then it stopped about 10 minutes later, and then it waited there for about 40 to 50 minutes, and then they told us that there was some problem with the train track,
and that we had to go back to Arjos, which we did, and then they told us to get off the train, at which point I said, you know what, I think we should seek an alternate mode of transportation. So now we have a rental car. This is accurate. Everything Bryce has said is true. I would have missed the train if he had not woken me up.
But that's because I was out late with the wonderful people of Roku. Shout out to Yaspur, Andreas, Jonas. There's a bunch of folks we met. And we had a fantastic time at the Roku's, symposium. If you are in or near Denmark next year, I think this is an annual thing that they do. It says on one of the websites that it's an invite only event, but invite only means those that are invited and the public is invited. So you can go. We met a bunch of folks that were not at Roku. Anyways, it was a great event. And we were out late. I mean, you left at 11,
but I was out until 1. And then I had to call my beautiful fiancé and talk to her. And so I didn't get to sleep until two. And I did plug my phone in and set an alarm, but I did not correctly put the hotel card in the electricity slot. And so everything died. But thankfully, Bryce woke me up at 801. Our train was at 815. I quickly packed, stopped off at a 7-Eleven to get a Coke zero, as one does. And I had four minutes to spare, which is pretty impressive. Ten minutes to pack, head out the door, pick up a beverage. And now we are, we're on the highway. The E45.
E45, beautiful Denmark. We love Denmark. And what else is there to say about our adventures this morning? Well, I don't know if there's anything to say about our adventures this morning, but, so we both gave talks at the Roku Engineering Symposium yesterday. And I gave a talk on modern Kuda C++ plus and kind of gave a talk on postmodern and C++. But there was also a talk
by two Roku engineers on like optimizing for binary size, obviously important for embedded programmers. And they talked a little bit about Roasted, which is their internal, like, core library. And
maybe you can give some of your thoughts. I thought the talks were fantastic. They used the morph transition very beautiful. I love it. I don't see it often, but I do see it more frequently now, and it was co-presented by Andreas and Jonas. And yeah, I was talking to them afterwards asking if we were able to mention the, so it's Roe Stood as RO and then STD, so a little play on the stood namespace. And I was asking them if we could mention it, and they said certain aspects of not what they
talked about yesterday, so I can't really go into details there, but they said, other aspects of their basically extension of the standard library is open source. So I will, when I'm editing this in a couple weeks, I will find that on GitHub, post a link in the show notes for those that are interested. And, yeah, it was a great talk. And I was, yeah, I was trying to think of all the different corporate, you know, standard libraries. There's the BSL, the Bloomberg standard library. There's the ASL, the Adobe standard libraries.
I know that EA, which is, I think most people are familiar with a games company, EA, it's in the game, whatever it is. EA Sports, it's in the game. I'll go find the actual clip, because anyone that's played like, you know, the NHL or FIFA games that are roughly plus or minus our age will remember that from their childhood. Anyways, there's a bunch of, they had the EA STL, but I had never heard of Roasted. Also, too, I, you knew this, I did not. I did not know that Roku was a spinoff of Netflix,
and it was initially like a team or it was inside of Netflix. I did not know that. Do you know that? Do you know the history of Roku? I knew about that part of it because I've had like a Roku for a long time because we don't really have any Apple devices in my household. And so if I want to watch Apple TV, I can't do it on my, like, tablet or my phone or anything or on my Android TV,
but there is an Apple TV channel on the Roku device, which is why we currently have and use a Roku. Actually, I think the current Roku that we use is one that was given to me at C++ by the C, a couple years ago, on the C. What is it? There's too many C++ and C conferences. I apologize to Phil Nash. I know that you listen every once in a while.
If you're listening to this, I apologize on Bryce's behalf. It is C++ on C. I actually don't know why they dropped the... I do think that the Dutch that have created C++ under the sea, they did the right thing by not being symmetric. Because I mean, C++ on the sea,
let's be honest. It's got a better ring to it than on C. And I actually, I don't know why there's no the. Do you know why there's no the? I don't know. We can ask Phil. I'm sure there's some poetic reason or it's a reference to something that we don't know.
I think maybe it's a play on words, but it's like C-plus-plus on C because, you know, C-S-E-A sounds like C-S-E-A sounds like C, the letter, the name of the programming language, so that's possible. Yeah, but a the-the doesn't obstruct that. No, because, like, if you said, like, C-plus on C as if, like, you don't say, like, the C, when you're talking about the C programming language, you know, you might say the C programming language, but if you're just, you know, referring to it, you just say C, C, or the C-C programming language. but the other thing that was interesting talking with the Roku folks and most of the people that we talked I guess we should give a little bit of context so Roku makes these little things that are called players that you can plug into your TV that let you like
it's a streaming media player they also now make their own TVs sort of a the closest analogy would be something like the Apple TV or the our guest Apple TV used to make a device or the Android TVs So it's basically they make like a smart TV, smart TVs,
and then they make devices that you can plug into your TV to turn it into a smart TV. And so a lot of the people we talk to were there people who work on the software that goes into the TVs. And this is obviously an embedded platform. It's not like, it's not like a, you know, a microcontroller. They're running Linux there, but it's a limited memory environment. And interestingly, despite the fact that they support back to some of their oldest devices, devices, that they're still supporting devices that are like 10 years old, they use modern C++ and they, when I asked them, they said that they pretty much they aggressively update to sort of the latest standards and latest compilers, and they deploy back to some of their oldest devices. And I thought that was really interesting because a lot of people who have like a long support cycle like that, they can't use more modern C++ because they're constrained by the operating system limitations on the older devices.
But in Roku's case, it's a closed ecosystem where they control the OS and everything, so they can push an update of whatever the latest OS and their entire stack. And that lets them be, you know, live it head and be very modern. I thought that was very interesting. And I think it would be great to see more talks from them about how they handle. embedded development with modern C++. Yeah, we talked to a few people
that said that they had given conference talks at some different C++ plus conferences. So I will go find those links and they will be in the show notes. I don't think I've seen a Roku talk at a C++ conference, but there are hundreds of videos out on the internet, so I'm not surprised that they have.
And yeah, it was interesting talking with the Roku folks. We also, we talked to a couple recent graduates and they were saying that the hiring landscape right now, it's pretty rough, pretty bleak. I, you know, I'd heard stories, but I had not directly heard from any university students, and they were saying that from the most recent graduates, what did they say, 75% have not found jobs.
So, yeah, not great, not great. Yeah, yeah, it was, so the fellow we spoke to, what was his name? Oh, it was Ryan, Ryan. He went school in the UK, got a CS undergraduate degree, and he got a job at Roku, and he'd said that he had an internship at Roku, and that basically all of the new hires at Roku, like the new college grad hires, have been people who had had internships. And that's certainly been my experience, that the only real, reliable way to get hired as, you know, a junior engineer coming out of college is to have had internships.
but yeah he said like 75% of his classmates did not have a job in tech and I don't remember what he said that they were doing if they were looking at other industries or if they were looking at going back to school but it is a tough a tough environment right now and even getting the internships I think is getting harder what was the well I saw some I thought I saw some roadkill which always makes me very sad but I don't actually think it was
I think it was some garbage that looked like a large rabbit, but it was not. There was, so Ramona and I were just on a safari in Africa, and, you know, Ramona really loves animals, and we saw two different, there were two different occasions where, you know, big cats were hunting something else, and Ramona was very traumatized the way that's just like, why can't, why can't we just all live together in peace and everybody can eat, eat the plants? And fortunately, I think for her mental well-being in both cases, the big cap did not catch the prey. I mean, that's, that doesn't make me sad because that's just the ecosystem working the way it should. Roadkill breaks my heart because
it's like humans that are... You would have, I think, been bothered by this because they were so many safari vehicles around we were watching this like uh cheetah like like uh you know going after this uh impala and then there was this little family of like wurt hogs with these four cute little baby warthogs but there were all there were so many safari vehicles there they sort of had boxed in the prey um and so it was like pretty clear that like the the people on safari were kind of interfering with what was what was happening there but uh but fortunately the uh the little impala got away and Ramona was very worried
about the Wirthawk and the Wirthawk Davies but when the Cheetah started going after that in Pala the Wirthog Mama started charging that cheetah and the cheetah
was like I am not messing with this this whirthog because the wurt hogs they don't get credit in Africa but they you know
a lot of people get killed by by wild boars and they're basically just like a slightly smaller version of a wild boar anyways this is a big
just to graduate And so why are we going to Copenhagen? We're going to Copenhagen. Well, first off, before we talk about our next stop, a couple more things to talk about the, well, we got the geographic stats, but also, too, we are in a poll star. Polestar were mentioned on one of our Tesla episodes. We had our to Tesla or not to Tesla.
Or I think, I can't remember what they were called. But anyways, we had two different episodes where I was debating it into Tesla. For the avid listener, you've had the update. We ended up buying a 2025 Toyota Piraeus plug-in hybrid. The hybrid, it's a great car, a couple issues with it, but overall, I mean, I do regret a little bit not getting a Tesla, but we're at Polestar. I've driven, what, 50 kilometers so far, something like that, and my review is, uh, I mean, you said that you like Polestar, but here's my issues. And I will say, you know, back when I was talking about getting a Tesla, I had driven a lot, but now I drive a lot more. and so I like to consider myself an informed expert
and things that I would not have noticed before there's only one fan pointing at my face I need to have you know I need to be constantly one of the best investments recently that I made was in a quiet Palanis fan was 100 bucks on Amazon I'm not sure if I've ever mentioned that Chima and I we have temperature wars back in our condo
and she would always be switching the AC to 23.5 or 24 or god help us she just turned it off and uh i'd come back from a run and i'm already like bleeding sweat and it feels like a sauna in the place and then i would always change it to 22 and that was basically we'd just go back and forth changing the temperature and you know it's kind of a joke uh you know a love language if you will and but then i i really decided that i couldn't handle this 23.5 24 nonsense so i bought a quiet fan it has been a game changer if you run hot blood at folks and you're in a temperature wars with your partner or you just want to save money on AC get yourself a fan who anyways you got to have you got to have the wind in your face when
you're driving a car to cool cool yourself down and they've got only one tiny fan on the left whereas my Toyota it's got fans all over the place I can point my two fans and also Shima's fan in the middle at me I got three fans and this one it's like what is it it's pointed at the roof at the windshield and also too I mean I know we don't like Elon, because of many reasons, but I don't understand why every goddamn car in the world does not copy their cell phone charger, like, model. In that is real simple, folks. You want two different chargers, one for you and your partner, and you don't want a slot. That's what the Prius has. It's a slot, so, like, it's ridiculous, and also it overheats the phones. What is a slot? What is a slot? So, picture, like, a little.
little toaster that you put a slice of bread in. It's like, replace the toaster with just a single thing that you can drop your cell phone in. And that's how they charge it. So instead of somewhere where you lay your phone, you drop it in, which obviously is inconvenient and just ridiculous. But they're trying to save space or whatever. I saw something that was like, oh, this is a great design. It saves space. Shut up. You don't need to save space. Your cell phone is an extension. We're all cyborgs. You need to be able to see it. Describe to us, Bryce, what the pole store does. well the pole star has one little like on the on the dash uh on the console the the center console there's like one little slot where you can put one phone and then on the right next to it there's
all right this didn't work this didn't work it's a lot simpler it's exactly like the Tesla except they reversed the way it's facing why would you why would you so like a Tesla's it's like a Tesla's like, you know, a slanted dash that's facing you. The Polestar has like inverted that. So it's a slanted dash, but it's facing away from you. So all you can see is the butt of your cell phone. What are you doing, Polestar? What are you doing? And honestly, every single car, when I looked into all the different electric vehicles, they all have some stupid take on how to do cell phone. Just copy Tesla. It's not, it's not even like, you know, this is not somewhere you need to be novel. And probably they did some study that says, oh, if you don't show the cell phone screen,
safer. Guess what? That's ridiculous. I need to see my, I need to see the percentage of the charge on my phone. And also, is it charging right now? I know that when I checked, I know that when I checked it, it did light up the screen and give you a little number, but like, I can't see right now if, if the screen is on or if it has a little percentage thing. Anyways, Polestar, it's a big swing to miss. And also, too, this car has the shortest distance from the steering wheel to the accelerator and brake pedals, which means that, like, my knees, are crunched up, and I'm pretty far back, and so, like, it's very awkward to, anyways, what are you doing, Polestar?
I, uh, Shima's cousin has a Polestar, and he has got rave reviews and says it's way better than Tesla. And, like, I don't like Elon, folks, and I didn't buy Tesla, but honestly, all stars and signs point towards Tesla. They got FSD, that's the reason we wanted in the first place, and, uh, now, uh, the love of my life has to drive the car. She doesn't like driving. She wanted the robots to do the driving.
let's just separate the art from the artist and buy Tesla next time folks that's my that's my little bit on Polestar's and Tesla's stay tuned in three months for the next time I've got a car review oh god where is I going to even go there
so many so many so many things oh god there was something I was going to say what was I going to say well you like Polestar so I don't know maybe you had something positive in your rents I mean I rent oh no I know what I was going to say so my my be
with modern car design or postmodern car design is cars, two things, two UI things. First of all, too many touch screens, we need tactile interfaces. Oh, that's, so that's the lovely thing about the, well, one of the lovely things. I have complaints about the Prius, but the Prius's screen, it is too small. We did, we got the XSE, which goes from an 8-inch screen to a 12-inch screen, but it's kind of one of those horizontal ones, but underneath the screen, or is it, is it underneath the buttons? they have a bunch of buttons that is very nice. So when you are messing around with basically all the car controls are still physical buttons,
the only thing it shows you is like your podcast player and Google Maps. And that's it. So that is quite nice because you do when you're driving. You don't want to be footsing around with like, you know, that's one of the complaints about the Tesla is like for certain settings. You have to hit four times. That is how you end up in a car accident is like trying to navigate to some menu so you can change something. In the future, we just speak to the car because it'll be a sentient, you know, system.
You know, how else you end up in a car? car accident is when you don't know how to use the shifter in the car because the car company has decided that for some reason the very simple intuitive interface of having a stick that you physically shift around that's in the center console no that needs to be reinvented we've we were in my dad and i rented uh this mercedes when we were in yosemite a couple years ago where the shifter was on the steering wheel, which isn't so bad, but, like, the way that it was designed, like, every time we had to put the car into reverse, we would nearly hit something. And then one time, Romona and I rented some, I think it was a GM, like, SUV, where the shifter
was, like, it was up on where the, like, the rear view mirror would be. And so you had to, like, reach up and press a button to shift. It's like, why, why are we reinventing this? Just put a stick, a physical stick, in the center. console. That's all you need. We didn't need to reinvent this. Major safety thing. But yeah, what are you going to do? Anyways, those are our car thoughts. Yes, and then the other thing I needed to mention, and I just turned up the, speaking of the wind, I just turned it up a little bit. So hopefully, hopefully this isn't ruining the listening experience. The other thing we learned,
what was it, was it, Andreas mentioned one of the speakers at Roku. He mentioned, obviously, it was a bit of a joke. But he said, basically everyone at Roku listens to ADSP. Oh yeah, and remember I got another thing to add that not to do with Roku. That is a big news, big news for folks. He said, he joked that everyone listened to the podcast. And I was like, huh, that's interesting. Because since coming to Denmark, first time in Denmark, beautiful country,
learned that the population is just under six million. So it's a rather small, in terms of population. It's a little bit smaller. And I was like, I wonder, you know, where Denmark is. in the rankings. So I hit up the stats on our website that we use. And Denmark is ranked number 11th, which is pretty high up there,
punching above its weight. And then I went and asked Gemini, I copied the top 50 countries and asked it to do a per capita calculation. And Denmark, the wonderful, beautiful people of Denmark, per capita are the number two country in terms of downloads and listenership. So we'd just like to shout out to our Danish listeners.
And, I mean, Bryce already knows this. If he didn't, I would play a little game. But the top five, quite surprising, quite surprising. Because obviously, or maybe not obviously, number one is the United States, but, you know, they're top five populist country in the world. Number one is Sweden. We love the people of Sweden. And we shout out to our Swedish listeners.
And number two is Denmark. Number three is Norway, where we're headed later in this trip. Number four is Switzerland. And number five is Finland. So all four of the top five countries by per capita. by listenership are the Scandinavian country. So I'm not sure what's going on there if we've got some promoters. And I think we don't really ask for ratings or reviews that often,
you know, once maybe every 100 episode. But I think what we should start doing is at the end of every year, or maybe every six months, we will do a podcast, statistics, you know, rankings kind of thing. And so obviously, you know, the Danish and the Swedish, they've got a history. And so I'm pretty sure Denmark, you know, the people of Denmark want to be number one. So we're not asking for reviews. But if you'd like to be number one, Denmark, you've got to specifically tell your Danish neighbors about the pod. But not any of them who live in Sweden.
Exactly. Well, I don't know if there's any Danish people living in Sweden. And also, too, if you've got friends in the States, you know, that doesn't help because you need to be, it's not by your nationality. It's where you're downloading from. And if you happen to be going to Sweden for the day, make sure you got your podcast download it already because if it what if we drop a pod on Friday and you happen to be doing some day visit but if you're doing that make sure you got the pod download before you go across the water across the pond and we'll see can Finland you know break into the top four and unseat
Switzerland and anyways I thought that was uh and I had no idea like I don't look at the stats very often but I thought it was interesting uh when Andreas mentioned that a lot of folks listen at Roku and and so I was like I wonder I looked it up and there it is number two, and also Slovenia, I think Slovenia is not in the top 10, but per capita, they are in the top 10. I think they're ranked number eight. Shout out to Slovenia, we do still love you. I realize that, like, we've been doing this podcast so long. I forget about all the antics that we had. We had a whole period where every second episode, we'd say
shout out to our Slovenian listeners, and we haven't done that, probably like, in a year or two. I have a theory, that your data's insights may be a little bit mistaken because you looked at first raw numbers of listeners per country then you looked at listeners per capita but i'm not sure that that's the applicable metric because maybe it's the case it's possible that more saw tech people in uh Sweden and Denmark and Norway listen to our podcast than in other countries but it's also possible that it's just that there's a higher rate of tech people in these countries relative to other countries. So what I think you really need to look at is not how many people are listening per the
population of the country, but how many are listening per the population of people in tech in the country? You think those stats are available for all 205 countries that we have, that's pretty impressive too when I looked it up. We got downloads in 205. So we basically, how many countries are there in the world. I think that there's, I don't know, it's just over 200, I think. I guess it depends. It depends on the UN statistic, but
I think it's 206 bones in the body in 195. So anyways, I don't actually know how we have 205 countries. I guess I should get in the right-hand lane. We got a Nissan behind us that... So I think that most countries probably publish
like breakdowns of their economy by sector and that might be able to tell you what percentage of their economy is in tech but yeah it's probably hard to get numbers about how many people work in tech per country but still anyway it's an interesting theory that maybe there's just more people in tech relative to the population in these countries i apologize to the people of denmark and of scandinavia bryce is trying to take away your your ranking and guess what i will ask jemini if they can do that but my guess is those stats don't exist.
But I am with the people of Denmark and the people of Scandinavia. In my hearts and in the true rankings, you will be in the top five. And hopefully Finland can hop above Switzerland and we can just have all four Scandinavian countries as our top four. But, I mean, if the statistics exist, I can make it happen. Or more accurately, the AI can make it happen. But, yeah. And did we already talk about the history of Arhars in programming languages? Yeah, we did a little bit.
And also, too, I have figured out the correct pronunciation. It's going to probably be a little bit off, but it's Orhus. It's not A, because it's an A with a little circle on top of it. I learned from, I got a haircut from Tom. Shout out to Tom. Tom definitely doesn't listen to the podcast. But I was supposed to get a haircut before I came, didn't have the time. So I got a haircut yesterday.
and we had a long conversation, giving me a great haircut. He told me a bunch of stuff. And one of the things, I went for a run yesterday, and I stumbled across this really beautiful apartments, waterfront apartments. And I looked it up afterwards,
and it actually is, according to some list, the number 12 thing to do in Orhus is to go check out Orhus, and then it's a O with a slash through it, or a zero with a slash through it. And you're probably wondering, what the hell does this have to do with Tom? I asked Tom, I was like,
what the hell is this like, is that a word? Is that a letter? He's like, oh, yeah, in Danish, we've got three extra letters. One is an A with a little circle on top of it, which now has, I think, I mean, I've seen it on the road, but a lot of the times to make things easier to type, they replace that with two A's. So Orhus, even though it's an A, spelled A-A, because it used to be the A with the circle, and it has a different pronunciation.
And then he told me that, oh, yeah, that's, I'm probably, I'm going to get my pronunciation a little long. The zero with a slash through it, or O with a slash through it, which is the O in Copenhagen, is u which by itself means island so orhus u means orhus island and anyways it was like some nicely developed stuff anyways they got three extra letters and it is the second most populous city in denmark i had no idea about that i did not i also did not know that do we know the the third should you look it up uh the third most uh cities in denmark by population i I've started using speech to text.
Actually, it's David Sanko's fault because we were at some conference and David Sankle was using speech to text to send text messages. And I told him like, oh, why are you doing that? Like, you know, why don't you just type? You know, it's probably faster to type. And my friend Eddie Nolan was there with me. And Eddie believed that he was probably the fastest texter in the group. So him and David had a race to see who could. put out a text message faster and in speaking it was actually you know like twice as fast and so now
I've I've started doing the speech to text instead of typing on the phone okay it's uh it's Copenhagen which is the Copenhagen metro area is 1.3 million uh the arhus uh city of arhus is uh 280 000 so pretty big drop off there really and yeah told me uh 380 Oh, this is, this is from pretty interesting. And then the next one is Odens, Odens, which is
180. And yes, there's a pretty big drop off. It's got one of those, it's one of those countries where there's just that one big giant metro area. And for the listener, you might have just heard some loud background noise. They've got some construction on the road,
which is making it very loud. And I have gone to the furthest, rightmost lane. and it is now very quiet but we are going very slow so I would just like you know we have sacrificed some time and it's our ETA initially was 1257 it's 1247 now and at 1 p.m. local time
is the 5,000 meter heats for the world athletics championships that is happening in Tokyo right now and my boy Grant Fisher who finished six in the 1,500 meters real disappointing double bronze in the Paris Olympics he's my favorite runner
he studied at Stanford which not most runners do. Anyways, he's got his chance at redemption. It's only the heats, so obviously he's going to be in the top six or whatever, have to qualify. But I'm hoping to watch the 5,000 meter heats, and I'm just letting you know, listener, I'm sacrificing potentially watching that live. Oh, and guess what? The noise is back because even the rightmost lane does not have a nice driving experience. So we're going back to the left, and the time that I said was being saved is not, and the audio quality is going to be poor. Part of the experience. Part of the experience.
So, oh, okay, can we, should we talk about the thing that you spoke about? Not yet. Not yet? We'll talk about it. Actually, when is this going to come out? I mean, you get to decide when it comes out. Well, I mean, there's two edited podcasts already. I edited the part one and part two, which are coming out as the third and fourth episodes of Sean.
So that's going to be, you've already listened to that in the past by now, but it is, what is it today? September 19th. Holy shit. Yeah, 19th. Right. The podcast, I need to launch. Oh, you were going to do it from the train, and we're not on the train. Yeah, we're six hours ahead.
So that means an 8. And 8. An 8 a.m. release is at 2 p.m. So it should be fine, but I totally forgot. I was about to say, yeah, the two upcoming episodes are on the 19th of the 26. And, ooh, we're on a big bridge. and that means that this episode we're probably seeing as we're not talking about technical stuff
as you probably made it what 30 minutes into this episode although we did mention the Roku folks that's technicalish I'll probably release this as one big one hour or whatever 40 minute episode however long we end up chatting for so that'll be on what October I don't know if it's the first second third something like that
but yeah let's hold off talking about that and we uh I mean we'll talk about it later on this trip, and then it'll get released. Ah, okay, okay, okay. At that point, we'll probably... Because I was thinking what we should do is we should, you know, we should do it like a guest interview, where I should interview you about,
like, oh, so Connor, tell me about this project you've been working on, you know? We'll do that, but my voice is fading, too, so... Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, let's talk about what we're planning on doing in Copenhagen and then the rest of our trip, and maybe we can wrap this up. Link in the show notes for the Roku Engineering Symposium. if you are in or near Denmark next year, roughly the same time, assuming that they've always done it in the past in Orhus.
Check it out. It is invite only, but the public is invited. And tonight, and that's the reason we got the car, is because we could have hung around the train station and crossed our fingers and hoped that the track issues were fixed. But Bryce did not want to take that chance. So we booked the car so that we can be at the Copenhagen C++, meetup, we're going to hang out with some more Danish folks, number two country per capita.
And we're both going to be giving the same talks again, modern C++ for GPUs for Bryce and postmodern C++ for GPUs for me. And I think there's a social or whatnot. I assume there's going to be some socializing. We're going to hand out some stickers. And that's going to be it for tonight, I think, right? Yeah, yeah, I think that's it. And then the day after we have finally day of rest on Saturday, so we're going to just be in Copenhagen, going to maybe go check out some things in the city, because I don't think either of us have been there before. And then day after that, on Sunday, we fly out to Toaslo, and we take the train to Kongsburg for in D.C. Techtown, and we've got two tutorials, one on Kuta C++, one on Kuda Python. I am, in
fact right now testing the Kudu-C-plus-plus one and then I've got to talk at the conference and then I head back. I actually fly back through Finland and then you're going to stick around for I'll be there for one day of the conference. I think you're going to stick around there for for both days at the conference and then that'll be the end of our little our little tour, a little Europe tour. Yeah and we'll have to, we're probably going to run out of stickers. We'll, we'll say that discussion for when it happens. And if we do, we'll be back. We'll be back.
I mean, we clearly have to come back to Scandinavia as this is where the people are. This is where the listeners are. Yeah, I'm excited. What, is there anything else we need to chat about in this episode? I don't think so. I think we can wrap it up. We've got two hours and ten minutes, it says, until we get to Copenhagen. Are we supposed to record anywhere?
I don't know. I mean, I think, I don't, I think not at the meetup, but presumably at NDC will, you know, run into some people we would want to record with or something. You, do you know, uh, I mean, this will all be in the past for the listener, but do you know off the top of your head who are the speakers that are speaking at NDC Techtown? I know, Jason's going to be there. I know, I don't know who else. I think maybe Hauna's there, I'm not sure. I think Hauna's there as well. Yes, it will be the first time being to a C++ conference in a long time for me. Like, when was the last C++ conference you were at?
Good question. It could have been ACCU, because most of the conferences I've been at Python conferences this year. Yep. So, haven't seen the C++ folks. It'll be good to catch up. Yeah, yes, it will. All right, well, let's wrap it here. Let's hope that worked. Be sure to check these shows. notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in
today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.